Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und alle anderen Themen, die da irgendwie noch mit dranhängen. Jetzt in Zusammenarbeit mit dem Zeiss Großplanetarium in Berlin. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich freue mich jetzt hier nach längerer Pause, im Prinzip die zweite große Welle, zu starten von Raumzeit, denn obwohl es eine längere Pause gegeben hat, in dem das eine oder andere organisatorische Detail neu ausgerichtet werden musste, geht es jetzt weiter hier mit zahlreichen Themen. Und wie immer steht ein Thema im Mittelpunkt und heute möchten wir einen Blick richten auf Kleinsatelliten. Und dazu begrüße ich Klaus Priess. Schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag, Herr Pritlove.
Herr Priess, Sie sind Professor an der TU Berlin, Institut für Luft- und Raumfahrt, sogenanntes Fachgebiet Raumfahrttechnik. Wie viele Fachgebiete gibt es denn bei der Luft- und Raumfahrt an der TU? Ist das mehr Luft oder mehr Raumfahrt?
Ja, wir haben sechs Fachgebiete im Institut für Luft- und Raumfahrt und davon sind fünf der Luftfahrttechnik gewidmet und ein Fachgebiet der Raumfahrttechnik. Wir bilden so im Jahr Größenordnung 3000 Studenten aus. Nicht verschiedene, aber 3000 höhere haben wir in unseren Veranstaltungen. Und bei mir sind es Größenordnung 300 in den Raumfahrtfächern. Wenn wir alle zusammenzählen, Größenordnung 40, Abschlussarbeiten pro Jahr kommen zusammen. Also ist schon etwas los bei uns. Die Studenten werden Master für Luft- und Raumfahrtechnik oder Bachelor für Verkehrswesen.
Es gibt ja gar nicht so viele universitäre Standorte für Raumfahrtechnik in Deutschland. Braunschweig würde mir jetzt als erstes einfallen.
Ja, es müssten insgesamt so circa sieben werden. Dresden, der größte ist Stuttgart, Universität Stuttgart, TU München, Fachhochschule Aachen und auch die RWTH Aachen. Ja, ich glaube jetzt haben wir schon fast alle.
Und Braunschweig halt.
Braunschweig hatten sie schon.
Genau. Gibt es aber auch schon lange den Fachbereich in Berlin?
Ja, das ist sogar der erste, der in Deutschland errichtet wurde für Raumfahrtechnik dediziert. 1963 hat man an der TU Berlin diesen Lehrstuhl geschaffen für Raumfahrtechnik und auch sehr prominent besetzt mit Professor Eugen Sänger, der aus Stuttgart dann nach Berlin kam und leider sehr früh verstorben ist, sodass 66 schon ein Nachfolger für ihn berufen wurde aus dem Werner von Braun-Team, Professor Kölle. Ja und das hat sich dann weiter entwickelt an der TU Berlin. Es kam dann noch ein zweiter Raumfahrtprofessur dazu, die wurde 1985 besetzt mit Professor Renner, mein Vorgänger. Ja und ich bin 2003 an die TU Berlin berufen worden, weil ich den Anspruch habe, auch Satelliten weiterzuführen, die mein Vorgänger Professor Renner dort erstmalig auch gebaut hat in Deutschland, mit Studenten und erfolgreich in den Orbit gebracht hat.
Genau, dafür ist ja die TU Berlin und insbesondere das Raumfahrtinstitut bekannt, dort eine besondere Rolle früh gespielt zu haben. Bevor wir darauf nochmal zu sprechen kommen, würde mich natürlich auch nochmal ein bisschen ihr persönlicher Hintergrund interessieren, bevor sie zur TU Berlin gekommen sind. War denn Raumfahrt schon immer ihr Thema? Oder sind sie ein Spät- oder Quereinsteiger?
Also wenn man so will, vielleicht mehr ein Quereinsteiger. Mein Hintergrund ist Elektrotechnik, Informationstechnik. Das habe ich studiert an der Technischen Universität Elmenau. Und habe dann auf dem Gebiet Kraftfahrzeugelektronik promoviert und später dann den Einstieg 88, 89 in die Raumfahrt gefunden, indem ich an der russischen Mars-Mission, damals Mars 94, später Mars 96, mitgewirkt habe als Gastwissenschaftler im Institut für Kosmosforschung der Akademie der Wissenschaften der DDR in Berlin. Ja und 1992 bin ich dann ins DLR gewechselt, das Institut für Weltraumsensorik in Berlin-Adlershof und hatte auch das Glück, konnte auch an dem Thema weiterarbeiten und auch mir neue Themenfelder erschließen.
Weltraumsensorik, das heißt dann sozusagen auch über diese spezifisch technische Linie quasi angedockt an das Thema?
Ja genau, die Elektrotechnik, Elektronik, das war der Zugang, wenn man so will. Ich hatte an der Kamera, die für die Marsbeobachtung gebaut wurde, verschiedene Beiträge geleistet und dann auch andere Anwendungen für Weltraumkameras versucht zu erschließen. Wir haben dann daraus überlegt, wie kann man aus einer Ozeanveranalyse Kamera entwickeln? Wie kann man die Kameratechnologie für andere Beobachtungen aus dem Weltall modifizieren? Der technische Ansatz war das, was mich getrieben hat als Ingenieur. Ich war immer daran interessiert, wie kann man Technik unter harschen Umweltbedingungen, unter sehr rauen Umweltbedingungen doch mit einer hohen Zuverlässigkeit zum Einsatz bringen. Das sind so die speziellen Herausforderungen, die einen Ingenieur doch sehr reizen.
Da war ja Ihr Start eigentlich eine kleine Enttäuschung, weil die Mars 96-Mission leider früh gescheitert ist. Was war da Ihre konkrete Rolle?
Ich hatte dort den spektralen und radiometrischen Feinentwurf gemacht, sodass man zum Beispiel Wasserwolken oder Kondenswolken auf dem Mars unterscheiden kann von Staubwolken und Staubschirmen, sodass die Kamera auch in der Lage war, autonom umzuschalten, das war so ein Beitrag, den ich geleistet habe, oder die Sensorik selber untersucht, Strahlungsfestigkeit der Sensoren, sensornahe Elektronikentwicklung, das waren so Themen, die ich da bearbeitet habe. Ja und das passiert halt hin und wieder mal im Raumfahrtbereich, dass auch ein Start daneben geht und dann ist natürlich Trauer angesetzt und man sucht nach neuen Themen, hatten wir aber schon vorher gemacht, nach neuen Themen gesucht, so dass man die Erkenntnisse, die man gewinnt beim Entwickeln von höchst anspruchsvollen neuen Technologien auch für andere Anwendungen schließen kann.
Aber trotzdem bestimmt kein besonders toller Tag, oder?
Das war sehr traurig.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Ja, es ist auch für viele, die noch mehr betroffener waren, da hängen ja dann so Doktoranstellen dran, die promovieren wollen auf dem Thema. Und plötzlich fällt der Gegenstein weg. Damit ist auch die ganze Stelle mehr oder weniger hinfällig geworden. Also das ist dann schon eine harte Sache. Man versucht natürlich dann neu wieder aufzulegen. Und das ist ja auch bei der Mars-Mission dann wieder. Da hat die ESA ja den Mars Express gebaut, wo die meisten Experimente wieder aufgehoben wurden und weitergeführt wurden. Also es ging dann doch weiter.
Da kam ihr Sensor auch zum Einsatz?
Ja, ne, dort nicht. Der kam auf der BIRD-Mission, das DLR zum Einsatz.
Was war das nochmal, BIRD?
Die BIRD-Mission, das ist die erste Kleinsatelliten-Mission, die das Deutsche Zentrum für Luft- und Raumfahrt gebaut hat. Start 2001 mit einem indischen, mit einer indischen Rakete. Und die hat Feuerfernerkundung aus dem Wild. Und ich hatte da die besondere Aufgabe, diese Mission zu leiten, das Projekt zu leiten von Beginn an. Und konnte so auch mich darum kümmern, dass die Mars-Kamera wieder redesigned wurde. Das war dann auch wieder ein Beitrag von mir, ein Fachlicher, den ich gerne gemacht habe, für Erdbeobachtung. Da mussten die Filter anders ausgelegt werden, die Aperture musste verändert werden. Man möchte aber die Kamera doch weitestgehend erhalten. Und dabei musste ich auch lernen, dass mit limitierten Ressourcen man auch manchmal ein bisschen konservativ sein muss. Wir wollten in dem Projekt Infrarot-Fernerkundung neu machen, komplett neu für Kleinsatelliten mit völlig neuer Technologie. Und das stand im Mittelpunkt dieser Birdmission. Und auf der anderen Seite bringen wir die Mars-Kamera, die ja schon ein paar Jahre alt ist, in Anführungsstrichen, zum Einsatz. Und da fällt natürlich den Ingenieuren auch eine ganze Menge Dinge ein, was man besser machen kann, neu machen kann. Und da war die Herausforderung, dass man nicht die Mars-Kamera noch mal redesigned und komplett neu entwirft, sondern, weil wir ja nicht beliebig viele Ressourcen zur Verfügung haben, sondern dass man die Kräfte konzentriert auf die neue Infra-Ozensorik. Das war also da so eine besondere Sache, wo man als Ingenieur, wo ich als Projektleiter dann auch ein bisschen bremsen musste, den Fortschritt.
Aber zu dem Zeitpunkt, denke ich mal, war so ihre Raumfahrtliebe aber auch schon vollkommen entfacht.
Ja, das war eigentlich mit dem Einstieg 88, wo ich dann an diesem Mars-Projekt mitwirken konnte. Vorher hatte ich ja an Elektronik für Kraftfahrzeuge gearbeitet, also auch in einer sehr harten Umweltbedingung. Das war schon mal eine sehr interessante Herausforderung und jetzt in den Weltraum, das war für mich sozusagen noch mal ein Schritt mehr in die extremen Anforderungen und wie kann man das beherrschen. Das war für mich noch eine noch größere Herausforderung, der ich mir natürlich gar nicht gestellt habe. Das war natürlich eine tolle Sache.
Also sie hatten schon so eine gewisse Grundaffinität schon für die Raumfahrt. Das war ja nicht total egal, ob es jetzt Auto oder Flugfahrt gewesen ist.
Nein, also Raumfahrt hat mich schon früher interessiert. Das muss ich auch sagen, nur war das damals nicht so, wie soll man sagen, Obatun, wo ich mich zum Studium beworben habe, dass man sagt, wir machen Raumfahrtechnik. Das gab es ja zu DDR-Zeiten nicht als Studium. Da hat man andere Dinge dann gewählt. Also Elektronik wollte ich von Anfang an machen. Das war für mich schon, bin durch Freunde dazu gekommen, mit Elektronik zu basteln. Das hat mir unheimlich Spaß gemacht und da wollte ich eigentlich auch mehr wissen, mehr verstehen. Und dann hatte ich mir schon immer Vorträge angehört über Raumfahrtergebnisse. 1969 war ja die Mondlandung der Amerikaner, das habe ich verfolgt. Und davor die sowjetischen Erfolge, der erste Flug eines Kosmonauten, Juri Gagarin. Das waren alles Themen, die fielen ja in meine Kindheit rein. Und die habe ich auch verfolgt mit größtem Interesse.
Und natürlich Sigmund Jen.
Sigmund Jen natürlich, ja.
Den ich ja hier auch schon mal zu Gast hatte. So und dann ist es diese BIRD-Mission geworden. Und damit hatten sie quasi das Thema Kleinsatelliten direkt unter ihrer Fuchtel quasi.
Ja, das hatte sich so im DLR, das DLR ergeben, dass das Deutsche Zentrum für Luft- und Raumfahrt wollte, sich dem Thema Satellitentechnik stellen, Kleinsatellitentechnik stellen und hatte mal einen Aufruf gemacht, Mitte der 90er Jahre innerhalb des DLR Vorschläge zu bringen, für eine Kleinsatelliten-Mission. Also die verschiedenen Forschungsinstitute aufgerufen und unser Vorschlag, eine dedizierte Feuerfernerkundungsmission auf einen Kleinsatelliten zu bringen und zu fliegen, die dann Ergebnisse liefert, die bisher nicht möglich sind, mit der fliegenden Technik zu bringen. Das hat Anklang gefunden bei der Programmdirektion und die Programmdirektion hat gesagt, das wollen wir, der Vorstand des DLR stand dahinter. Und wir hatten einen Institutsrechter bekommen, Professor Röser, der auch gesagt hat, ich will das mit diesem Institut durchziehen, sodass sich diese Satellitenentwicklung dort so gestaltet hat.
Das heißt, es gab in dem Sinn auch noch gar keine kleinen Satellitensysteme, auf denen man hätte groß aufbauen können?
Nee, das Institut hatte damals enorme Fachkompetenz auf dem Gebiet Weltrauminstrumente für extraterrestische Anwendungen oder für Erdfernerkundung. Das war die Know-how-Basis, auf die man aufbauen konnte. Aber auf dem Gebiet Satelliten war noch keine explizite Kompetenz da. Aber man konnte natürlich auf die große Erfahrung und die großen Kenntnisse der Experten setzen, die schon diverse Raumfahrtinstrumente gebaut haben, dass man auch dem neuen Thema sich stellen kann, Satellitentechnik. Und das war neu. Ich hatte das Glück auch Lehrgänge zu besuchen, die mir da auch ein gewisses Fundament gegeben haben. Und ja, und dann kam der Direktor, Professor Röser, und hat dem Vorstand gesagt, er macht das mit diesem Institut für Weltraumsensorik und sorgt dafür, dass diese Satelliten- Mission zustande kommt und hat sich dann im Haus nach einem kleinen Projektleiter umgeguckt. Ich war auch im relativ jungen Alter noch von so 40. Also ich war nicht der erfahrenste, aber mich hatte die Sache unheimlich interessiert, weil das was völlig Neues war. Und ich auch vorher schon mich mit dem Thema Kleinsatelliten ein bisschen beschäftigt habe, sodass die Wahl auf mich fiel. Ich war sehr froh und habe das gerne aufgegriffen und übernommen.
Wie definiert man denn diesen Begriff Kleinsatellit? Also ein Satellit ist ja zunächst einmal so ziemlich alles, was da draußen rumschwirrt. Typischerweise hat man so, ich weiß nicht, mindestens einen Kühlschrank im Kopf, wenn man dran denkt. Aber wir haben ja auch teilweise Satelliten gesehen, die auch komplette Busse im Prinzip hätten ausfüllen können. Wie unterscheidet man zwischen groß und klein an der Stelle? Was ist das? Gibt es da irgendeinen etablierten Maßstab oder ist das eher eine Definitionsfrage von den Fähigkeiten?
Also es ist nicht wirklich international definiert, aber so an Nährungsweise ist die Fachwelt sich einig. So 800 Kilogramm bis oder 1000 Kilogramm dort ist so die Grenze nach oben von konventionellen Satelliten. Die bezeichnen wir dann als konventionelle Satelliten, die schwerer als 800 Kilogramm sind und darunter aus meiner Sicht sind das auch noch ziemlich große Satelliten, aber so bei 400 Gramm Kilogramm Gesamtmasse sagt man, das ist schon mal ein kleines Satellit, manche sagen auch Minisatelliten dazu. Historisch hat sich das so entwickelt, dass die Satelliten immer größer wurden, Tonnen schwer, eine Tonne, zwei Tonnen, drei Tonnen, vier Tonnen.
Noch mehr Instrumente, noch mehr.
Ja, noch mehr und in den 85 startete plötzlich eine amerikanische Universität, einen ganz kleinen Satelliten, der nur, ich weiß nicht mehr wie viel Kilo, vielleicht 30 Kilo oder so, gewogen hat. Also was ganz kleines und dann hatte mein Fachkollege, mein Vorgänger Professor Renner, auch die Idee, so was zu bauen und dann sahen diese ganz kleinen, doch neben den großen Satelliten, mit denen die mit gestartet wurden, sehr winzig aus und da hatte man kein anderes Wort und die als Mikrosatelliten bezeichnet. Die haben nichts mit 10 hoch minus 6 zu tun, aber sie waren eben im Vergleich zu den damals normalen Satelliten. Tonnschweren waren eben ganz ganz winzig und mickrig und klein und hat man die als Mikrosatelliten bezeichnet, sodass diese Klasse 50 bis 100 Kilogramm heutzutage Mikrosatellit heißt. Alles, was so ein großer Satellit so einfach mal so mitnehmen kann.
Ja, to go.
Ja, heute sagt man to go. Die Satelliten wurden noch kleiner, weil die Elektronik kleiner wurde, der Fortschritt ging weiter und man konnte noch kleiner bauen. Und dann tauchten plötzlich neben den 100 Kilogramm Mikrosatelliten jetzt 10 bis 20 Kilogramm leichte Systeme auf. Und da suchte die Fachwelt dann doch nach einer Abgrenzung und sagte, ja, das ist aber doch was anderes als die 100 Kilogramm. Da kann man ja auch nicht genau das Gleiche mitmachen. Die sind ja doch sehr limitiert in den Leistungsparametern. Und weiß nicht, wie man auf die Idee kam. Jedenfalls bürgerte sich der Begriff Nano-Satellit dann ein, weil das ja die nächste Größenordnung wäre. Von Mikro nach Nano hat aber natürlich nichts mit 10 oder minus 9 zu tun. Und noch eine Nummer kleiner, ein Kilogramm leichter, zwei Kilogramm. Da sagt man heutzutage Pico-Satellit, wenn man will. Und eine besondere Gruppe der Pico-Satelliten sind die sogenannten Cube-Sats, die dann eine Würfelform haben und einen Standard entsprechend den Kallpulli definiert hat. Das hängt damit zusammen, dass die in speziellen Auswurfcontainer mit in den Orbit genommen werden müssen und von diesem Auswurfcontainer aus starten, in den Orbit freigesetzt werden. Und alle die Satelliten, die diese Spezifikation erfüllen, die Cube-Sat-Spezifikation, die nennt man eben Cube-Sats, von der Würfelform abgeleitet. Ja und wie das so ist bei solchen Entwicklungen mit einem Cube-Sat, der ist ja doch sehr klein, 10 mal 10 cm, Kantenlänge mal 10 cm, sehr limitiert in den Ressourcen, in der Performance, ist man nicht ganz zufrieden, so dass auch dort Doppel-Cube-Sats und Dreifach-Cube-Sats Gang und Gebe sind. Die nennen sich dann auch Two-Unit-Cube-Sats oder Three-Unit-Cube-Sats und heutzutage werden auch schon sechs-Unit-Cube-Sats gebaut in den Orbit gebracht und man redet davon, dass man auch sechs-Unit-Cube-Sats zur Mond fliegen möchte. Das sind dann schon wieder mit den anderen Griffen bezeichnet Nanosatelliten.
Mischt sich so ein bisschen, haben aber dann wiederum dieses Spezifikum, dass sie quadratisch, also kurvisch angelegt sind. Ja genau. Okay, also wir haben unterhalb der normalen Satelliten, die über 800 Kilo enden, Mikrosatelliten oder Kleinsatelliten, Mini, Mini, Mini, Mikro. Ne, Mini, Entschuldigung, Mikro ist dann 50 bis 100, sagten sie, darunter Nano, darunter Pico und dann eben diese spezielle Form CubeSat. Ich nehme an, das sind sozusagen sowieso fast alle Pico-Satelliten, sind dann letztlich CubeSat. Wenn man schon so weit gegangen ist, da ein Standard für den Launch zu schaffen, zeigt das ja auch so eine gewisse Bedeutung. Wann war diese erste Launch eines Kleinsatelliten, als Herr Renner dann sozusagen auf die Idee kam?
Wenn ich richtig bin, 1985 mit dem Space Shuttle. Das hatte so einen Container für Experimente an Bord und der startete dann aus einem Container raus. Wurde durch eine amerikanische Universität aus Utah gestartet. Das war meines Wissens der erste Kleinsatellit, also von Universitäten gebaut, der gestartet wurde.
Ist ja auch eine nachvollziehbare Geschichte, insofern, als das ja gerade Space Shuttle für seine enormen Kosten bekannt war und man sozusagen dann auf die Idee gekommen ist, wenn man jetzt hier sowieso schon so viel Zeug da hochschießen, dann könnte man ja vielleicht die eine oder andere Lücke noch füllen. Oder war das jetzt wirklich einfach nur im Rahmen des experimentalen Bereichs des Space Shuttle Programms gedacht?
Also man hat dort einen Experimentcontainer gehabt für verschiedene Flugexperimente, die in der Ladebucht untergebracht waren. Aber es war noch nicht so standardmäßig vorgesehen, dass man da Free Flyer, sozusagen Satelliten, aussetzt. Als man das erfolgreich gemacht hat, ging eigentlich so eine kleine Welle los und man hat gesagt, ja prima, das können wir eigentlich machen und den Universitäten anbieten. Und da haben sich sofort unheimlich viele amerikanische Universitäten gemeldet und gab es eine Warteliste oder die wurden ausgelost. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie es genau gemacht wurde. Es war jedenfalls dann eine kleine Bewegung im Gange und von meinem Vorgänger weiß ich, Professor Renner, der hatte auch die Idee dort mitzufliegen, hat sich auch eine Wartennummer geholt, um dort mit zu starten. Aber leider war ja 86 dieses, naja, taurige Challenger Unglück und dann war mit diesem Programm Schluss. Dann hatte man zwar die Idee gehabt, ja, so kleine Satelliten zu bauen an der Universität, aber die Startmöglichkeit, die man sich ausgeguckt hatte, die fiel dann weg und Renner sagte mir, dass der Professor Jäger auf ihn zugekommen ist, irgendwie Ende der 80er Jahre und sagte, wir könnten doch mit der Ariane so einen kleinen Satelliten mitnehmen. Jäger war ein Absolvent der TU Berlin und arbeitete bei Ariane's Buzz in der Vermarktung auch von Ariane-Raketen. Man weiß, dass Ariane-Raketen natürlich auch einen stolzen Preis haben. Das war damals ein riesen Erfolgsmodell, Ariane 4. Das darf man nicht vergessen, das war kommerziell ein Weltmarkterfolg ohne gleichen. Aber es hatte doch seinen Preis, so ein Start mit so einer leistungsfähigen Rakete, sodass man sich, also Universität kam erst mal nicht auf die Idee, dort irgendwie mitzufliegen. Aber es sind dann doch europäische Universitäten und kleine Einrichtungen darauf gekommen, da mit zu starten. Der große Satellit oder die zwei großen, die zahlen den Start der Rakete und die anderen zahlen noch mal einen Beitrag. Und das hat dann funktioniert. Und mein Vorgängerpräsent, Renner, hat dort auch dann 1991 seinen ersten Satelliten, den Tubsat A, gestartet, den er mit Studenten zusammengebaut hat.
Und das war dann auch in welcher Kategorie?
Die 50 Kilogramm Klasse.
50 Kilogramm, also so ein Mikro?
Genau.
Mikro Satellit. Wie groß muss man sich den so vorstellen?
50 Zentimeter Kantenlänge. Das war damals auch eine wichtige Größe. Die Grundfläche durfte nicht viel größer sein als 50 Zentimeter mal 50 Zentimeter, weil so viel Platz hatte man dort gelassen auf der Oberstufe, dass man mehrere solche Kleinen dort starten konnte.
Also war also auch schon dieses quadratus, dieses kubische Modell sozusagen war schon...
Naja, das Quadra-Modell. Nach oben hin war man variabel, da hatte man noch Luft.
Aber so eine Standfläche von 50, 50 musste eingehalten werden.
Die musste so eingehalten werden und da hatte dann Ariane auch mehrere vorgesehen. Also es gab dann richtig so einen zusätzlichen Auswurfmechanismen, die von anderen Ariane dann auch standardmäßig angeboten wurden, die dann diese Maße einhalten mussten und dann hatte Ariane dort angeboten für kleine Satelliten, sie mitzunehmen.
91 war das?
Ja, 91.
Das heißt, es gab auch schon bei dem Start mehr als nur den Turb-Satelliten?
Es gab mehr, ja und ich glaube, es gab auch schon 90 so einen ersten Start mit mehreren kleinen Satelliten, aber da war schon bei den ersten dabei.
Ja, die Turb-Sats, die sind ja recht bekannt, würde ich sagen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ich habe da schon mal was von gehört. Das ist ja jetzt auch nicht so selbstverständlich, dass man im Rahmen der universitären Ausbildung so weit geht. Man denkt sich ja mal so, Studenten, die setzen sich dann so hin und die dürfen dann auch mal was löten. Man bleibt dann aber so im Wesentlichen in der Theorie und wenn man so seine Physik zusammen hat, dann darf man dann auch mal irgendwann mal ran. Aber dass man eben so weit geht, dass man selber konzipiert, plant, baut und dann eben auch bis hin zum Launch alle Anforderungen erfüllt.
Bis zum Betrieb sogar.
Richtig, bis zum Betrieb. Ich hatte jetzt gerade vor allem auch diesen Launch noch in Erinnerung. Ich habe ja hier mal eine Sendung auch gemacht zum Rexus-Bexus-Paket von dem DLR, wo ja auch Studenten angehalten sind, dazu machen. Und da wurde halt schon ausführlich dargelegt, was es doch auch für die Studenten bedeutet, sich nicht nur so mit der Technik als solchen, sondern eben sozusagen auch mit dem gesamten Prozess der Qualitätssicherung, der regelmäßigen Überprüfung, diesem ganzen Hinarbeiten, dem Einhalten von Deadlines, dass man sich solchen Sachen auch schon ausgesetzt sieht, die ja später dann einfach bittere Wahrheit sind, dass das sozusagen auch schon Teil der Ausbildung ist. Ich vermute mal, das dürfte hier bei den kleinen Satelliten der TU Berlin auch eine große Rolle spielen.
Ja, genauso ist das. Das war zwar jetzt nicht das originäre Ziel damals, sondern man wollte erst mal überhaupt was Praktisches machen. Das ist ja schon für eine Universität doch ein bisschen ungewöhnlich. Das haben sie schon völlig richtig dargestellt. Universität macht universitäre Lehrer auf einem hohen Niveau, verbindet natürlich Theorie mit Praxis, mit den neuesten Forschungsergebnissen. Die Studenten haben die Möglichkeit ja auch die neuesten Forschungsergebnisse in der Vorlesung zu hören. Das ist schon mal eine tolle Sache. Aber an der TU Berlin war eben rund der Anspruch, auch praktische Erfahrungen mitzugeben und die kann man nicht per Vorlesung mitgeben. Da muss man den Studenten wirklich ransetzen, muss sagen, hier, jetzt wollen wir mal was zusammenbauen und auch testen am Boden, dass alles funktioniert. Und diesen Ansatz hat mein Kollege damals durchgeführt und sehr, sehr erfolgreich auch durchgeführt, so dass der Tubsat-A, der ja im Wesentlichen ein Kommunikationssatellit war aus heutiger Sicht, das war ja endlich ein Forschungssatellit. Man hat versucht, überhaupt ein Satellit zusammenzubekommen. Der nur so klein ist mit den Komponenten, die man damals zur Verfügung hatte. Das sind ja zum Teil kommerzielle Bauteile und das, was man aus dem Raumfahrtbereich übernehmen konnte, war in der Regel zu groß, zu schwer, zu teuer. Es war also schon eine enorme Herausforderung, so etwas überhaupt zustande zu bringen. Und der Tubsat-A hat Kommunikation sichergestellt und daraus entwickelten sich ja dann auch später dann Anwendungen, die man vorher gar nicht so gesehen hat.
Also er hat erstmal die Kommunikation mit dem Satelliten sozusagen hergestellt.
Ja, dass man mit ihm reden konnte und dass er selber Daten runtergesendet hat, das war ja erstmal nur ein Universitätssatellit. Zum Demonstrieren, dass wir Betrieb machen können, wir Universitäten, wir können auch Satelliten betreiben, wir können entbauen, starten, betreiben. Das war das Hauptanliegen von dem Tubsat-A. Und dann kamen auch Leute an, die wollten dann diesen Satelliten nutzen, indem sie sagten, ja wir machen, das weiß ich, der Arvid Fuchs kam zu dem Herrn Renner und sagte, ich möchte den mal so eine Wanderung zum Nordpol machen und brauche, wäre doch schön, wenn ich da noch so eine Kommunikationsverbindung hätte über einen Satelliten. Kann man da nicht was machen? Und da hatte sich dann das entwickelt, das musste man erstmal ausprobieren, wie könnte das funktionieren? Es musste ja möglichst einfach laufen und das war dann auch erfolgreich durchgeführt worden. Kommunikationsverbindung, dass Nachrichten ausgetauscht werden konnten, vom Pol aus abgesendet werden konnten, nach Deutschland und von Deutschland über den Pol, so dass da zumindest zeitweise ist ja dann nur eine minutenlange Verbindung. Solange der Satellit im Sichtbereich der Empfangsantenne am Boden ist, kann man die Verbindung aufrechterhalten und dann ist wieder Schluss.
Das heißt, der Satellit ist auf dem polaren Orbit unterwegs?
Ja, der war auf dem polaren Orbit unterwegs. Ich weiß nicht mehr die Höhe, ich glaube 800 Kilometer oder so. Das bedeutet, man hat so vielleicht acht bis zehn Minuten Kommunikationszeit im günstigsten Fall und dann ist er wieder für 80 Minuten nicht mehr zu sehen.
War das dann so eine, also er hat quasi so als Kommunikationsrelay funktioniert? Ja, genau. Konnte ihn sozusagen anfunkten und er hatte dann die... In dem Moment gleich weitergeleitet? Also hat er sozusagen nur seine Position ausgenutzt?
Ja, er hat die Position ausgenutzt.
Okay, also nicht so als Zwischenspeicher und zwei Stunden später gibt das dann wieder an?
Das kam später dann, als Store entfohrt. Also der hat die Position ausgenutzt und konnte dann die Verbindung sicherstellen.
Das ist ja schon mein realer Nutzen, weil sonst muss man da ja auf Satellitentelefon die Netzwerke zugreifen, die es, weiß ich gar nicht, zu dem Zeitpunkt glaube ich noch in dem Maße gar nicht gab. Da gab es dann noch nicht mal GPS richtig.
Ja, das ist jedenfalls nicht so nutzbar.
Genau, noch nicht so allgemein verfügbar. Der Erfolg hat ja dann sozusagen eine ganze Serie ausgelöst. Also das blieb ja nicht der einzige, sondern dem Tubsat A folgten weitere Modelle. Vielleicht weiß ich nicht, inwiefern sie da Einblick haben, aber wie technisch komplex muss man sich sozusagen diesen ersten Tubsat vorstellen? Also was muss man da, da war ja nicht so viel rein. Was war überhaupt drin? Ich meine, wenn ich so zurückdenke, 91 und so, da war das ja auch mit der Elektronik alles noch nicht so gedient, zumindest nicht mit der Elektronik, die glaube ich so für kosmische Strahlung ausgelegt war.
Ja, das ist richtig. Mit diesen Anforderungen musste man natürlich klarkommen, aber an sich hat der Satellit genau die gleichen Subsysteme wie ein großer tonnenschwerer Satellit. Er muss, eine Ausnahme des Antriebssystems, aber er muss eine Struktur haben, dann muss er ein Thermalkontrollsystem haben, dass die Elektronik, die eingebaut ist, in diesem engen Temperaturbereich gehalten wird, bei allen wechselnden äußeren Bedingungen. Das ist ja Elektronik und die Temperatur, die wir hier für unsere Computer brauchen, die muss der Satellit dort eben auch halten. Und ja, dann brauchen wir eine Energieversorgung. Die wird klassischerweise über Photovoltaik umgesetzt. Er fliegt von den 90 Minuten ca. 35 Minuten im Schatten. Und dort will man auch, dass noch wenigstens Funkverbindung besteht, wenn er im Schatten über die Bodenstation fliegt.
Also im Funkschatten?
Ja, ich meine jetzt im Sonnenschatten. Also auf der Nachtseite fliegt. Und man hat die Bodenstation in der Nacht. Und man weiß jetzt, in Überflug möchte man ja eigentlich auch Kontakt aufnehmen. Und dafür braucht man dann auch Elektroenergie. Also muss er Batterien an Bord haben. Man braucht das Kommunikationssubsystem. Dann braucht man eine irgendwie geartete Lage, Stabilisierung oder Regelung. Bei den großen Satelliten ist das alles schon sehr fortgeschritten. Bei den kleinen gab es eben da keine geeigneten Bauteile. Aber eine Art Lage-Stabilisierung hatte auch der TUBSAT A.
Also in Form von Düsen dann?
Nein, das war eine magnetische Stabilisierung. Man nutzt das Magnetfeld der Erde aus und kann jetzt ein Magnet einbauen in den Satelliten. Dann ein Permanentmagnet, dann richtet der sich erst mal aus. Man stabilisiert die Lage oder man baut Spulen ein und kann dann auch aktiv ein Magnetfeld erzeugen und dann damit auch seine Richtung ändern, in dem Magnetfeld der Erde. Pfiffig.
Das reicht aus.
Ja, wenn man keine hohen Anforderungen hat. Also wenn man jetzt keine High-Gene-Antenne, also so eine leistungsfähige Antenne hat, die eine große Richtwirkung hat, sondern die mehr nach allen Seiten ausgerichtet ist, dann reicht das aus. Wenn man da die Lage stabilisieren und vielleicht relativ ungenau den Satelliten ausrichten können. Also mit Magnetspulen kann man den Satelliten auf mehrere Grad genau sogar ausrichten, wenn man das will. Ja, Kommunikationssystem.
Das ist dann auch energetisch nicht so aufwendig, das zu tun.
Nee, da fließt Strom, dann entsteht ein Magnetfeld und dann hat er sich erstmal ausgerichtet. Und er hat ohnehin einen Restmagnetismus, das kann man nicht verhindern. Irgendwo ist da noch ein Restmagnetismus drin. Und das stabilisiert ja dann auch die Lage. Sorgt ja dafür, dass er weiter rumtaumelt, sondern so nach und nach wird die Taumelbewegung abgebaut.
Das ist sozusagen von Anfang an schon ein Problem, weil er in dem Moment, wo er ausgesetzt wird, kann er sich sozusagen in einer beliebigen Rotation befinden.
Ja, er wird erstmal taumeln, jeder Satellit. Man sagt ja landläufig, der wird abgesprengt, aber eigentlich wird ein Pyrozünder ausgelöst. Der kappt dann irgendeine Halteverrichtung. Das ist meist ein Seil oder etwas anderes, was durchgeschnitten wird. Und dann wird ein Federmechanismus freigegeben und der Federmechanismus drückt dann den Satelliten raus. Das sind mehrere Federn, die werfen den so aus. Die haben unterschiedliche Federkonstanten oder Toleranzen. Die haben die gleichen Federkonstanten, aber mit Toleranzen, sodass dieser Ausstoß nicht so perfekt ideal ist, so schön harmonisch, von allen Richtungen genau gleichförmig, sondern da kriegt er einen kleinen Anfangstrahl. Und dann taumelt er rum und würde jetzt die Taumelbewegung beibehalten, wenn ihn nichts ausbremst. Was kann ihn ausbremsen? Das sind die Störungen, die der Satellit im Orbit hat. Da wären zum einen Restluftteilchen der Atmosphäre. Aber das sind dann Moleküle oder Atome. Je nachdem, in welcher Höhe er sich befindet, sind immer noch Restteilchen. Die bremsen den auch ein bisschen aus. Dann haben wir die Sonne. Sonnenwind. Den Sonnenwind. Der stellt schon mal eine ordentliche Größenordnung dar. Dann haben wir die Ungleich- förmigkeit der Gravitation der Erde, die den ja auch noch zerrt. Oder überhaupt die Gravitationskraft der Erde zerrt noch mal am Satelliten und will ihn auch irgendwie ausrichten. Aber er fliegt ja nun doch mit einer großen Geschwindigkeit. Mit 7,7 Kilometer pro Sekunde im Orbit ist also sehr schnell woanders, wo wieder andere Gravitationskräfte wirken. Die zerren also an und wollen und versetzen den und halten den auch in irgendeine Drehbewegung oder Taumelbewegung. Und jetzt muss man also, man möchte den Satelliten doch lagemäßig irgendwie stabilisieren, in definiertem Zustand bringen. Das muss jetzt nicht immer so sein, dass der dann still steht, inertial orientiert, im Raum fest, sondern es reicht ja auch aus, wenn der eine definierte Drehbewegung hat. Aber dass man eine stabile Lage einnimmt. Und da gibt es mehrere Möglichkeiten. Und eine Möglichkeit ist magnetische Stabilisierung. Entweder passiv, indem man einfach bloß ein permanentes Magnet reinbaut und sagt, jetzt rüchtet er sich schon irgendwie an den Feldlinien der Erde aus und bremst sich ab mit der Zeit, das funktioniert. Wenn man damit zufrieden ist, ist das okay. Oder wenn man sagt, ja, wir wollen eigentlich den Satelliten genau ausrichten. Und das war bei dem TUBSAT-B der Fall, der zweite TUBSAT, der hatte schon ein hohes hochauflösendes Teleskop an Bord mit, ich glaube, das war geplant, Wenimeter Bodenauflösung, war schon ein richtig ein sehr ordentliches Instrument. Dann muss so ein Satellit in allen drei Achsen stabil ausgerichtet werden. Da kann man sich jetzt nicht zufrieden geben, da trauen wir schon irgendwie rum und wir machen ein paar Bilder und dann trifft der schon mal die Erde. Und so machen es ja heute diese kleinen Cube-Sats zum Teil noch. Da war dann die Anforderung, den möchten wir ausrichten. Für Großsatelliten ist die Technologie schon seit ewigen Zeiten, seit Beginn der Raumfahrt mitentwickelt worden, weil man das auch für Raketen brauchte. Da nimmt man zum Beispiel Reaktionsräder, das sind Schwungräder, die dann die Störungen aufnehmen, die der Satellit erfährt durch das Rumtaumeln. Die erzeugen dann einfach einen Gegendrehimpuls. Der Satellit hat einen Drehimpuls in der einen Richtung und das Schwungrad erzeugt einen Drehimpuls in die andere Richtung, bis diese Drehbewegung aufgenommen worden ist. Und das macht er dann mit drei Rädern in aller Achse.
So eine Art Bewegungspuffer, in dem so das Taumeln quasi aufgenommen wird.
Genau. Das Taumeln wird erstmal in den Rädern gespeichert als Drehimpuls. Und ist dann erstmal drin. Es ist noch nicht weg. Es ist dann nur in den Rädern aufgefangen.
Aber es ist kontrolliert und messbar.
Ja, es ist kontrolliert und wir haben mit den Rädern die Störungen, das was man nicht haben will, weggenommen. Wenn er zial stillstehen soll, dann wird er stillstehen und die Räder drehen sich. Aber er steht still. Oder wenn er zur Erde gucken soll und sich langsam abrollen soll, so dass er immer nahe dir guckt mit seinen Instrumenten, dann besorgen das auch die Räder. Und die Störungen, die auftreten, kommt so ein Solar-Flair oder irgendwas, gibt es ja noch mal einen Impuls. Dann nehmen die Räder das einfach auf und erhöhen ihre Drehzahl. Und solche Räder gab es für Kleinsatelliten nicht. Und da war Herr Renner einer der ersten, der solche Räder für Kleinsatelliten entwickelt hat und in den Tubsat eingebaut hat. Er ist auch Elektroingenieur von Hause aus und sagt sich, ja das ist ja ein Elektromotor mit einer Schwungmasse. Diese Aufgabe können wir uns stellen. Wobei das natürlich alles nicht wirklich ganz einfach ist. Das muss ja auch sehr rund laufen, sehr ausgewuchelt sein. Und er hat dann die ersten Reaktionsräder für Kleinsatelliten entwickelt. Also auch so eine Pionierleistung. Und damit war der Tubsat B dreixenstabilisiert, hatte ein ordentliches Teleskop an Bord, mit dem man ordentlich Erdaufnahmen machen konnte. War eigentlich eine tolle Sache. Nur kam der ewig nicht in den Orbit, Startverzögerung und so weiter. Und hat nachher nur eine kurze Lebensdauer im Orbit gehabt. Man weiß nicht genau, warum nicht länger.
Vor 39 Tagen hat er, glaube ich, nicht gehalten.
Ja, aber immerhin hat man jetzt an der Universität schon neue Technologien für diese Kleinsatelliten entwickelt, die dann auch bei den nachfolgenden Satelliten sehr gut zum Einsatz kamen.
Das scheint mir jetzt überhaupt auch schon nochmal so ein interessanter Aspekt zu sein. Man hat am Anfang, mag man ja denken, ok, kleine Satelliten, da besteht es im Wesentlichen aus dem Weglassen von Features. Aber das ist ja sozusagen nicht das Einzige. Das ist ja im Prinzip so, wie, was weiß ich, so wie sich Laptops zu den Minicomputern damals verhalten haben, dass man eigentlich nochmal eine extra Ingenieurleistung bringen muss, um diese Miniaturisierung überhaupt erst hinzubekommen. Weil ja nicht alles, was man in groß bauen kann, kann man dann auch in derselben Qualität und Zuverlässigkeit automatisch auch klein bauen.
Ja genau, das ist eigentlich so der Punkt. Das lässt sich nicht so einfach runterskalieren. Jedenfalls nicht bis zu dem gewünschten Maß meistens. Und das ist eigentlich auch so die Herausforderung, der wir uns gestellt haben. 2003 hatte ich an der Uni dort den Lehrstol übernommen. Und die TUBSAT-Serie war ja eine sehr erfolgreiche Serie. Die war auch technologisch sehr gut ausgereift. Also ich hab dort neu angefangen und wollte natürlich auch neue Dinge machen. Und mich der Aufgabe stellen, noch kleinere Satelliten zu bauen. Eigentlich eine ganze Klasse kleiner. Also die Satelliten von der Rena, die sind ja die Mikrosatellitenklasse. 50 bis 100 Kilogramm.
Genau, mit so einem 38 Zentimeter Raster ging es los. Dann 32 so die Größen und wurde auch langsam immer kleiner sozusagen.
Ja, er hatte sogar zwei Nanosatelliten gebaut, die jeweils acht Kilogramm leicht waren und von der russischen U-Boot-Archete gestartet. Die sind relativ niedrig eingeschossen worden und haben dann deswegen nur ein halbes Jahr im Orbit funktioniert, aber sehr erfolgreich. Also hat er dann auch die Pionierleistung auf dem Gebiet der Nanosatelliten vollbracht. Ja, und wie ich angefangen habe, wollte ich noch einen Tick kleiner werden und diese ein Kilogramm leichten Satelliten leistungsfähig machen. Das war so die Herausforderung, die ich mir vorgenommen hatte. Da sah es ähnlich aus, wie vor 20 Jahren bei den Mikrosatelliten. Es gab eigentlich keine ordentlichen Komponenten, die man verbauen konnte für CubeSats. Das geht also los. Auch dort muss, wenn man dort mit der Kamera die Erde aufnehmen will und auch diesen Anspruch haben wir, dann braucht man eigentlich eine Drei-Achsen-Stabilisierung, wie auch so ein Mikrosatellit. Aber für solche kleinen gab es nichts, außer die Magnetfeldstabilisierung, die nicht sehr präzise ist. So dass eins unserer ersten Forschungsthemen, das wir aufgegriffen haben und auch gemeinsam mit einer Firma angepackt haben, mit der Berliner Firma Astro-Feinberg-Technik, war die Entwicklung von Reaktionsrädern für CubeSats. Die haben also so einen Durchmesser von vielleicht zwei Zentimetern, sind einen Zentimeter hoch und davon drei in so einen CubeSat eingebaut plus Ansteuerelektronik. Dann haben wir so schon mal ein Fünftel des CubeSats-Volumens ausgefüllt, aber wir sind in der Lage, Dreihachsenstabilisierung zu machen und das war eins der ersten Forschungsthemen, das wir bearbeitet haben und auch einen entsprechenden Satelliten dazu, wo wir auch zum Teil Unimittel eingesetzt haben, eine Berufungsmittel habe ich dort mit eingesetzt. Ein Satelliten, der demonstriert im Weltraum, dass diese Räder auch geeignet sind für den Weltraum-Einsatz und für für Lageregelungsaufgaben. Ja und das war der, wir haben das BISAD genannt. BISAD steht für Berlin Educational and Experimental Satellite, weil wir auch damit sofort Studenten einbezogen haben, damit Studenten Ausgebildete haben. Sie spielten, diese Satelliten spielten eine leere Rolle, aber auch in der Anfertigung von damals Studienarbeiten, Diplomarbeiten, später Masterarbeiten, Bachelorarbeiten. Also sind viele Generationen von Studenten, möchte ich jetzt schon sagen, haben auch an diesen CubeSats, die wir hier entwickeln und entwickelt haben, großen Anteil und sich auch selber damit weiter qualifiziert. Ja und für diesen kleinen CubeSat braucht man genau die gleichen Subsysteme wie für einen größeren Satelliten oder für einen Mikrosatelliten. Wir brauchen eine Struktur, ein Thermalkontrollsystem, ein Energieversorgungssystem, ein Kommunikationssystem, ein Lageregelungssystem. Das sind die üblichen Satellitensysteme, die auch die Kleinen brauchen und dafür aber auch die Komponenten. Da es aber nicht ausreichend vernünftige Komponenten gibt, in der Winzigkeit haben wir also mehrere Forschungssysteme aufgemacht, Miniaturisierung von Komponenten und uns Partner gesucht, die nach Möglichkeit diese Prototypen, die wir entwickeln, so als Universitäts... Wir sind ja zufrieden, wenn wir einen Prototypen, der funktioniert, hinbekommen und den in Norwich schießen, da sind wir ja, haben wir ja schon unsere Aufgabe eigentlich erfüllt. Aber wir haben uns industrielle Partner gesucht, die auch ein Interesse haben, selber Know-how reinzupacken, weil sie dann aufbauend auf den Erkenntnissen nachher ein Produkt weiterentwickeln können, die dann aufbauend auf diesen Prototypen sagen, das wollen wir dann aber weiterentwickeln als Produkt und das dann auf den Markt bringen. Ja, also haben wir zum Beispiel einen Sender im S-Bandbereich entwickelt mit der Firma Eiko Wireless aus Berlin für CubeSats. Und das Besondere ist eigentlich, dass normalerweise in CubeSat nicht so viel Leistung bereitstellen kann, dass man einen S-Band-Sender damit betreiben kann auf Satelliten. Und hier war so die Idee, dass man sehr leistungsfähige Kodierung ansetzt und dann eintauscht Sendeleistung gegen Kod gewinnen. Und das haben wir dann mit der Firma gemeinsam entwickelt als Forschungsprojekt. Und die Firma hat es dann weiter zum Produkt entwickelt. Und dieser S-Band-Sender ist eben geeignet für CubeSats. Wir haben ihn noch nicht auf Satelliten gehabt, aber schon auf einer Höhenforschungsrakete. Der hat also schon mal Weltraum gesehen und auch Raketenstartbelastung erfahren. Nämlich genau diese Rexus-Raketen. Alle zwei Jahre gibt es die Möglichkeit für Universitäten, ein Experiment auf Rexus zu implementieren. Und wir hatten mehrmals diese Möglichkeit auch genutzt. Und eine war eben, dass wir gesagt haben, wir wollen mal diesen Sender mit einer Rakete starten und betreiben auch während des Fluges. Und das war, ja, ich glaube 2006. Da haben wir dann auf ein Rexus-System den Sender und noch verschiedene CubeSat-Technologien aufgebaut. Das sind dann meist auch Studentenprojekte. Und dann ist eine kleine Gruppe von Studenten mit einem wissenschaftlichen Mitarbeiter zum Startplatz nach Corona gefahren, haben dort die Startkampagne mitgemacht und auch den Flugversuch. 174 Kilometer Höhe wurde erreicht, das war eine zweistufige Rexus. Das hat also schon wirklich Weltraum gesehen. Per Definition beginnt der Weltraum.
Aber leider nur ein paar Minuten.
Nur ein paar Minuten, ja. Okay, aber die Stabbelastung braucht nur ein paar Minuten. Für uns war es ein Erkenntnisgewinn.
Ja, nee, ich wollte das gar nicht schlecht machen. Nur nochmal darauf hinweisen, dass es natürlich viel interessanter ist, wirklich jetzt einen dauerhaften Orbit einzunehmen. Und natürlich auch den Langzeitbetrieb anzustreben. Vielleicht nochmal kurz diese TU-Satelliten-Historie hinzubekommen. Also es gab diese TUBSAT-Serie, da fallen glaube ich sechs Satelliten. Drunter? Sieben. Sieben? Okay, von denen zwei auch noch im Betrieb sind. Zwei Kreisen nach wie vor um die Erde.
Das hängt jetzt von der Höhe ab.
Das meinte ich natürlich. Also welche, die sozusagen auch wirklich im Betrieb sind. Was heißt denn das konkret? Also gibt es dann bei Ihnen im Institut sozusagen auch, wie man das so jetzt vom ESOC in Darmstadt gewohnt ist, so einen tollen Raum mit großen Bildschirmen, wo Leute rund um die Uhr sitzen und mitzittern, ob er auch die nächste Runde schaffen wird?
Also es gibt so ein Missionskontrollzentrum, das ist nicht ganz so groß wie das ESOC, und auch nicht wie das GESOC. Es ist natürlich der Universität angemessen, aber ich muss sagen, für eine Universität haben wir schon ein sehr gutes Missionskontrollzentrum. Und in dem werden auch Studenten ausgebildet, richtig in Fragen des Missionsbetriebs. Wenn wir Glück haben, dann passt die Vorlesungszeit oder die Zeit der praktischen Übung mit einer Überflugzeit eines Satelliten zusammen, sodass diese Studenten auch mal im Missionskontrollraum erleben, wie schnell gehen denn diese 7-8 Minuten Überflugzeit vorbei, wenn man am Terminal sitzt und wackelnde Zahlen sich anschaut und muss dann beurteilen, ja, wie geht es den Satelliten und so weiter. Das und vielleicht sogar noch Kommandos abschicken, das erlebt man dann live als Student bei uns und findet vielleicht Spaß dran. Der ein oder andere Absolvent ist sogar dann ins Deutsche Raumflugkontrollzentrum gegangen oder auch ins ESOG hatten wir auch schon, das Europäische Raumflugkontrollzentrum. Ja, also Betrieb ist für uns auch eine wichtige Komponente in der Ausbildung und in der Forschung. Das wollen wir und wir haben deswegen auch großen Wert auf diesen Betrieb gelegt. Aber ich muss dazu sagen, standardmäßig brauchen wir nicht täglich diesen großen Kontrollraum, brauchen die auch nicht im ESOG, sondern nur, wenn die großen Aktionen stattfinden. Wenn ein Satellit ausgeworfen wird und man sucht den Erstkontakt und will dann auch sehr schnell einschätzen, gibt es irgendwo eine Schwierigkeit, die wir nicht vorher gesehen haben, müssen wir reagieren, dann muss man eben alle möglichen Systeme auf den Blick haben.
Schwierigste Phase bei jeder Mission.
Ja, der nach dem Auswurf, die ersten Orbits, die Start- und frühe Orbitphase, sagt man dazu. Ja, und da müssen die ganzen Experten der Subsysteme vor ihren Terminals sitzen, und jeder hat seine Seiten aufgeschlagen, wo die Gesundheitsdaten des Satelliten, die Housekeeping-Daten zu sehen sind, und schätzt dann ein, so und so ist die Lage, und wir können jetzt die oder jene Manöver durchführen. Das ist dann für uns auch natürlich der spannende Moment. Wenn dann ein paar Tage erfolgreich gelaufen sind, dann...
Darf man auch mal wieder schlafen....
Es sind immer weniger zu sehen im Kontrollraum. Und dann irgendwann macht man das von seinem Schreibtisch aus. Oder auch von zu Hause hat man dann die Display-Anzeigen im Internet. Kann man sich die abrufen, nicht jeder. Aber jeder, der das muss und darf und will, kann das abrufen.
Also es hat natürlich alles nicht die Dimension, die jetzt ein Start einer großen Mission hat. Aber es hat alle Aspekte davon. Es hat die Planung, es hat die Abstimmung mit dem Launch-Part. Man muss auf die Anforderungen eingehen, die insofern durch diese Standardisierung natürlich stark vereinfacht sind. Weil man muss sich jetzt über den Platz nicht immer im Detail abstimmen, sondern man hat da sozusagen seinen Slot. Da passt man dann rein. Man muss die und die Größen einhalten. Und es sind in der Regel auch immer dieselben, sodass das an der Stelle etwas entspannt ist. Ich glaube, sonst wäre es auch für die Launch-Unternehmen auch irgendwie zu komplex, zu kompliziert, zu teuer, sozusagen diese ganzen kleinen Gäste noch mit dabei zu haben, wenn man jetzt mit jedem noch mal ein eigenes Abstimmungsprogramm fahren müsste. Oder?
Also wenn es diese ganz Kleinen, die CubeSat betrifft, die würden da nicht mit starten können. Das wäre dem Launcher zu anstrengend für so einen Kleinen, noch alle Review-Prozeduren und wirklich sicher zu gehen, dass da nichts passiert und so weiter. Für den ist jetzt dieser Standard wirklich eine tolle Erleichterung. Der Standard besagt, dass so ein CubeSat aus einem geschlossenen Container heraus gestartet wird. Solange der Start stattfindet, ist der CubeSat komplett in einem Container mit Klappe vorne zu drin. Die werden zwar alle am Boden getestet, dass nichts passieren kann während des Starts, dass die Startbelastung aushält. Das wird alles getestet, viel für den Großen auch. Aber es schafft noch mal eine zusätzliche Sicherheit, dass dieser Container da ist. Falls doch irgendwas nicht richtig gemacht wurde, bleibt es in den Kasten drin. Und es schädigt nicht den Großsatelliten, denn das ist ja dann doch eine ganz andere finanzielle Dimension auch. Also nicht, die Größe ist irgendwie auch proportional mit dem Preis, mit den Kosten.
Ja klar, weil es ja auch vor allem das Gewicht ist. Zunächst einmal natürlich auch der Platz, aber vor allem das Gewicht, was bezahlt werden muss in Sprit und letztlich natürlich auch Platz. Vielleicht noch mal kurz, weil ich finde das ganz faszinierend, weil man macht sich das glaube ich so am Anfang gar nicht so klar. Also das ja im Prinzip jetzt auch im Hinblick auf die eigentliche Ausbildung, meine ich, so viele Sachen dabei sind. Also wir hatten jetzt Launch, also Planung, Bau natürlich klar, die ganze Technik, überhaupt Sensorik etc., sich einen Kopf machen über Protokolle, was man überhaupt letzten Endes an Anwendung fahren will. Zu der Phase, wie ist denn das eigentlich mit den Sensoriken, die sie einbauen, gibt es dann sozusagen auch innerhalb der Uni oder an anderen Universitäten auch interessierte wissenschaftliche Gruppen, die dann auch, wie man das bei den großen Missionen kennt, quasi so als wissenschaftliche Zuarbeiter oder Nutznieser dieser Sensorik arbeiten oder ist das dann wiederum auch eigentlich, verbleibt das eher im studentischen Bereich in ihrer Abteilung?
Also wir bauen ja nicht so eine Fernerkundungsmission für Fernerkundler oder so, sondern wir sind fach wie die Raumfahrt-Technik. Wir kümmern uns um die Technik und bauen dort unsere eigenen Experimente. Wir machen vor allen Dingen Technologie- erprobung im Weltraum und Technologie- demonstrationen, aber nicht nur für uns. Wir nehmen auch andere Technologie- Experimente mit von anderen Universitäten und Forschungseinrichtungen. Wir haben jetzt in der Entwicklung den Technosat-Satelliten, das ist ein Nano-Satellit, 15 Kilogramm schwer, der wird im nächsten Jahr starten und der hat von der Uni Würzburg einen besonderen Sternensensor und eine Kamera, eine besondere Kamera mit. Der hat einen Teilchendetektor und Zähler vom DLR-Zentrum in Bremen mit an Bord und mehrere Instrumente oder mehrere Technologie-Erprobung von unserem Fachgebiet, von neuen Technologien, die wir entwickelt haben, die wir im Weltraum demonstrieren wollen. Sodass Sie sehen, wir machen jetzt nicht, der ist kein Fernerkundungs-Satellit, aber wir werden neue Technologien erproben, weil diese kleinen Satelliten, die Nano-Satelliten und Octi-Cube-Sats, die haben noch nicht diese technologische Basis, mit der man das machen kann im Weltraum, sondern das muss erst entwickelt werden. Diese Aufgabe stellen wir uns als Universität, als Fachgebiet Raumfahrtechnik, sehe ich das als eine wichtige Forschungsaufgabe an, hierfür ordentliche Technik zu sorgen, die auch Raumfahrtaufgaben erfüllen kann und deswegen ist eine Forschungsrichtung bei uns ein Kompetenzfeld, Miniaturisierung von Raumfahrtechnik. Wir sehen also zu, dass wir alle Komponenten, die man für einen Satelliten braucht, möglichst klein bekommt und vielleicht sogar noch in einer höheren Integrationsstufe. Nur mal so als Beispiel, üblicherweise sind ja das Solar-Array ist ein Bauteil, Magnetspulen ist ein zweites Bauteil, Sonnensensoren oder Sonnensensoren ein drittes Bauteil. Das braucht man alles im Satelliten, das muss integriert werden, hat eigene mechanische, elektrische, thermale Schnittstellen. Wir haben diese drei Bauteile in eins integriert, das ist eine Wand und fliegen das bereits auf dem Bizarre 1, hatten das vorher auf der Höhenforschungsrakete schon mal abprobt. Das ist also ein Modul und ein Forschungsthema bei uns beschäftigt sich damit, den Integrationsgrad noch weiter zu treiben. Dort wird noch eine S-Band-Antenne integriert, mit der es möglich ist, dann hohe Datenraten runterzusenden und sie ahnen schon, dass das nicht ganz einfach ist. Hier fließen schon mal Ströme durch das Solaree, dann haben wir eine S-Band-Antenne, die eigentlich elektromagnetische Felder aussenden soll, aber da ist ja schon mal ein elektromagnetisches Feld auch durch die Spule da. Wie beeinflusst das sich gegenseitig?
Kann man das auf engstem Raum vor allem?
Ja, auf engstem Raum kann man das noch vernünftig beherrschen, sowohl mathematisch, modellmäßig als auch technisch, physikalisch in der Wirklichkeit. Sinn ist allerdings, dass wir eben mehr Nutzlastraum zur Verfügung stellen können, mehr Nutzlastkapazität in solchen kleinen Cubes hat. Deshalb wollen wir immer mehr Komponenten an den Rand drängen. Wir haben ein anderes Forschungsprojekt, wo auch diese Reaktionsräder durch eine völlig neue Lösung ersetzt werden, die dann an der Wand auch noch integriert wird, sodass im Cube hat nachher selber viel mehr Platz für Nutzlasten ist. Das können auch Kameras sein, optische Instrumente oder auch Instrumente, die das Weltraumwetter beobachten. Da gibt es eine Reihe von Nischenanwendungen, wo diese Satelliten hinzielen können. Aber unser Thema ist vor allen Dingen Entwicklung dieser Raumfahrt-Technologien.
Forschung und Lehre findet ja beides statt. Hör ich jetzt bei beidem auch stark heraus. Man lernt ja sozusagen das Rüstzeug, alles, was man zur Technik und auch zur Durchführung von Missionen machen muss. Aber im Prinzip ist dieser Betrieb zum Zweck der Lehre, erfordert sozusagen auch automatisch eigentlich einen extremen Forschungsaspekt. Es geht nicht nur irgendwie etwas nachzuvollziehen, damit man was gelernt hat, sondern im Prinzip ist ja hier so ein Innovationsteil schon mal quasi kommt einfach mit oder ist einfach erforderlich, wenn man hier voran marschieren will. Ist es denn so, dass diese Ergebnisse dann auch wiederum in die Raumfahrt auch unmittelbar einfließen?
Sie meinen, die Raumfahrt lehre?
Ja, wenn sie jetzt sagen, sie haben eine Konzentration zum Beispiel auf die Miniaturisierung, es müssen halt komplett neue Systeme erfordert werden, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das Interesse daran durchaus gegeben ist in der Raumfahrtindustrie oder zumindest in anderen Forschungsbereichen.
Ja, also wir haben verschiedene Anfragen, auch diese Ergebnisse weiter zu nutzen. Manches entwickeln wir ja schon gemeinsam mit Firmen, die sagen, das ist eine interessante Geschichte, da wollen wir auch sofort die Ergebnisse gleich in die Praxis überführen, in die Industrielle. Andere Dinge brauchen noch eine gewisse Vorlaufzeit, wo die Industrie dabei ist und dann erst mal schauen will, aber das ist schon so, wir veröffentlichen und freuen uns dann, dass auch Industrie auf uns aufmerksam wird und sagt, das interessiert uns, aber da wollen wir auch mehr darüber wissen und da wollen wir auch vielleicht mit euch zusammenarbeiten. Ja, also jetzt ist an verschiedenen Stellen sind unsere Forschungsarbeiten im Gange. Ein Thema ist Satellit der Zukunft, sage ich jetzt mal so landläufig. Das Forschungsthema selber heißt bei uns AIBOS. Das steht für Intelligent Building Block Satellite System. Das ist also ein wartungsfreundlicher Satellit, das mit dem Grundanliegen, Weltraummüll zu vermeiden. Ja, vielleicht braucht das ein paar Sätze zur Erklärung. Üblicherweise lebt so ein Satellit 10, 15 Jahre im Orbit, also ein großer kommerzieller Satellit und muss dann irgendwie entsorgt werden. Allerdings klappt das nur teilweise. Die geostationären Satelliten, die müssen ihre Position verlassen und werden dann 200 bis 300 Kilometer weiter geparkt in dem Friedhof Orbit und verbleiben dort. Satellite im niedrigen Erdorbit sollen in die Atmosphäre eintauchen und verglühen. Das klappt für die, die relativ niedrig fliegen, so 500, 600 Kilometer. Das klappt ganz gut aufgrund der Natur der Sache. Fliegen sie höher, klappt es nicht so gut, weil da zu wenig Luftteilchen sind, die sie ausbremsen. Da sind die dann 100 Jahre und länger noch im Orbit. Jetzt ist eine Idee zu sagen, lasst uns doch die Lebenszeit der Satelliten verlängern. Da entsteht auch weniger Schrott, wenn wir alte Bauteile im Sinne von, ja, sind technisch veraltet oder auch im Sinne von funktioniert nicht mehr. Alte Bauteile austauscht gegen neue, modernisierte und den Baukasten- Satelliten entwickeln. Und das ist ein Forschungsthema bei uns, wo die Industrie dabei ist, wo Forschungszentren dabei sind, ein so genannter Building-Block-Satellite oder Baukasten-Satellit. Wir tauschen Bauteile aus, wenn sie überlebt sind und ersetzen die durch neue. Wir müssen allerdings sicherstellen, dass das alles von den Schnittstellen passt. Und das ist eben Teil der Forschung. Wie muss so eine Schnittstelle aussehen? Zwischen verschiedenen Satelliten-Blöcken. Wenn wir uns so einen Quadra vorstellen, dann müssen wir da eine Thermalschnittstelle bauen. Wir müssen eine Energieschnittstelle, eine Datenschnittstelle, alle diese Schnittstellen, die wir sonst auch brauchen, müssen dort implementiert werden und funktionieren sehr zuverlässig. Das ist so ein Thema, dem wir uns stellen von der Raumfahrt-Technologie, wo dann später die Industrie die Erkenntnisse nutzt und das dann hoffentlich in industriellen Praxis umsetzen kann.
Ich verstehe nicht ganz genau, Sie meinten ja, Weltraumschrott solle verminen werden. Das ist im Wesentlichen erst mal darin, dass man nicht alles, was man hochschießt, auch wieder runter bekommt, unabhängig jetzt von der bundelaren Bauweise.
Das ist dann der nächste Schritt, dass man das auch wieder runter bekommt. Aber hier ist ja schon mal dadurch, dass wir nicht einen Satelliten komplett neu ersetzen und sozusagen neuen nachschießen, weil der Alte seine Aufgabe erfüllt hat. Nach 10 oder 15 Jahren schießt man neuen nach. Hier setzt man Bausteine nach, tauschen die Bausteine ein Sorgenleben in den Erdorbit.
An dem bestehenden Satelliten wird ein Baustein ausgepauscht?
Ja, sodass dieser Satellit als Grundkörper 30 Jahre, 40 Jahre, 50 Jahre fliegt und nicht durch drei Generationen von Satelliten.
Aber wie können sie den denn einfangen?
Der wird nicht eingefangen in dem Sinne, sondern dort wird der servicefreundlich gebaut, wird ein Service-Satellit, wird andocken, wird ein Baustein austauschen und dann fliegt er mit dem alten Baustein weg und entsorgt den.
Ein Update im Orbit sozusagen?
Ja, genau. Ein Update im Orbit.
Ja, das gibt es ja doch so in der Form noch eigentlich gar nicht, oder?
Gibt noch gar nicht. Es arbeitet die NASA dran und wir. Also wir heißt mehrere deutsche Universitäten und Forschungseinrichtungen. Und auch Industrie, das wollte ich sagen. So ein Beispiel, wo wir eben sehen, dass da auch ein großer industrieller Nutzen dahinter steht. Ja, natürlich ist auch die andere Richtung ganz wichtig einzuschlagen. Was gibt es denn für Entsorgungsstrategien? Das hat jetzt damit jetzt nichts zu tun, sondern auch Vermeidung von Müll, in dem man zum Beispiel eine Flächenentfaltung macht, sodass der Luftwiderstand größer wird oder der ist ja nicht Luftwiderstand, sondern der Widerstand größer wird.
Wenn sozusagen besser eingefangen wird. Aber das ist jetzt bei den bisherigen CubeSats auch noch nicht unbedingt Teil des Konzepts gewesen, sondern das kommt jetzt hier sozusagen auch noch dran.
War nicht Teil des Konzepts. Unser Strategie bis jetzt ist so, dass wir sagen, wir suchen Staats aus, die uns tief genug einschießen, sodass wir dann innerhalb von ungefähr 25 bis 35 Jahren entsorgt sind.
Was sind das, 200, 300 Kilometer?
Nee, das sind bis 600, 20, 30 Kilometer. Okay, das reicht schon. Man kommt da schon sehr hoch und dann hat er noch eine Lebensdauer im Orbit von 20, 30 Jahren. So ungefähr.
Aber jetzt an aktiven Komponenten würde sich sozusagen nur so was wie ich klappe mich auf...
Ja, oder ein Antriebssystem. Aber das nur für die Entsorgung einzubauen, kenne ich jetzt kein Beispiel.
Ja, weil das ja dann auch sehr viel, da muss man wieder Treibstoffe mitnehmen. Ja, genau.
Und es setzt auch voraus, dass das Lied auch funktioniert noch. Das ist ja nicht immer gegeben.
Ende seiner Lebenszeit.
Ja, das ist nicht immer gegeben. Man könnte ja auch sagen, wir definieren zwei Jahre Lebensdauer im Orbit, dann ist er noch funktionsfähig und dann wird er entsorgt. Das sind natürlich bestimmt ein paar Leute traurig, wenn man das gezielt dann macht. Aber das ist auch eine Entsorgungsstrategie. Wäre also auch was sinnvolles.
Aber das Thema ist ja wichtig. Also ich hatte ja auch schon in der siebten Ausgabe mal Holger Krag vom ESOG unterhalten, die ja glaube ich in der Zwischenzeit dann auch dieses Space Awareness Programm nach vorne gebracht haben, was ja sozusagen die allgemeine Beobachtung einschließt. Auf der einen Seite aber eben auch die internationalen, die Umsetzung der Abkommen überwacht, dass eben auch alle neuen Launches den modernen Gepflogenheiten, der Weltraumhygiene entgegenkommen. Das heißt heutzutage wird ja nichts mehr hochgeschickt, was nicht auch einen klaren Plan hat, wie es entweder definiert aus dem Weg gehen kann oder eben den Weg zurück auf die Erde findet. Naja, das ist dann sozusagen auch Teil der Ausbildung natürlich heutzutage.
Also auf jeden Fall gehört das zu unserer Ausbildung. Leider ist es noch nicht so gängige Praxis, dieser Code of Conduct, der ist ja eine freiwillige Vereinbarung und da gibt es leider immer noch zu viele Ausnahmen. Ist das so?
Schwarze Schafe.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall die richtige Richtung. Eine freiwillige Vereinbarung ist schon mal viel besser als gar keine. Und natürlich hängt das jetzt von den Ländern und Organisationen ab. Wir als Universität kriegen viele Forschungsprojekte durchs DLR bezahlt. Wir müssen uns danach richten, ganz klar. Wir können uns jetzt nicht aussuchen, dass wir das nicht einhalten. Das ist kein Thema. Aber es gibt eben andere, die sagen dann, ja, für uns zählt das nicht. Oder diese Untersuchungen, die sind viel zu schwarz gefärbt. Wir erkennen die nicht an. Also so eine Standpunkte gibt es in der Fachwelt. Es ist also leider noch nicht so, dass es durchgängig akzeptiert ist, dass dieses Weltraum-Thema ganz aktiv angegangen werden muss. Und das ist aber Bestandteil unserer Ausbildung. Da sind wir in den Lehrveranstaltungen immer dabei, den Studenten erst mal das Thema, überhaupt die Brisanz des Themas klar zu machen. Und dann auch, wie können wir dort alternative Wege aufzeigen?
Jetzt viel schon häufiger der Begriff, man sucht auch nach neuen Anwendungen und Einsatzmöglichkeiten. Ich denke, auf jeden Fall haben sich diese kleinen Satelliten schon längst von diesem reinen experimentalen Forschungsunterrichts-Aspekt gelöst. Also der besteht nach wie vor. Es sind aber eigenständige Forschungssysteme, die gegebenenfalls auch komplett neue Anwendungen erschließen. Welche Bedeutung kann man denn jetzt diesen kleinen Satelliten in allen Abstufungen, von Pico bis Mini, so beiführen? Also welche Anwendungen werden durch solche kleinen Satelliten überhaupt erst möglich oder zeichnen sich ab? Welche Rolle spielen sozusagen die kleinen Satelliten in der Raumfahrt als Ganzes?
Also hier sehe ich, dass viele Wissenschaftsnischen bedient werden können. Die hören sich zwar erst so harmlos an, sind aber doch von großer Bedeutung. Also nehmen wir mal das Beispiel Frühwarnung oder auch ein anderes Beispiel Katastrophenmonitoring. Ja, wir haben zwar tolle Technologien, auch auf der Erde und im Weltall, werden aber dennoch von Tsunamis überrascht, von Vulkanausbrüchen, trotz des hohen technologischen Reifegrades der örtischen Technologien und das liegt daran, dass noch nicht wirklich der globale Blick da ist, solche Ereignisse rechtzeitig zu erfassen. Jetzt hat man ein seegestütztes System als zur Tsunami-Frühwarnung entwickelt, bestehend auf Brojen werden Messungen gemacht und wenn jetzt die Tsunamiwelle kommt, dann kann man wenigstens Stunden vorher die Landbevölkerung warnen. Ich hab mir sagen lassen, Brojen werden weggeschleppt, herzündlich aufzufinden. Das System ist sozusagen löchrig. Die Experten vom Geoforschungszentrum Potsdam beherrschen zum Beispiel exzellent die Auswertung von GPS-Daten, von GPS-Reflektionsmessungen. Wenn GPS-Satelliten Signale aussenden, dann werden die auch zum Teil auf der Erdoberfläche reflektiert oder auf der Wasseroberfläche und können auch vom Satelliten wieder aufgefangen werden und ausgewertet werden. Man muss dann allerdings auch ausrechnen, wie sind sie durch die Ionosphäre verzögert worden und so weiter. Und dann, wenn dieser Prozess genau genug beherrscht wird, ist es auch möglich, eine Tsunamiwelle aus dem Orbit zu erkennen. Wenn ich allerdings das zu einem ordentlichen Zeitpunkt machen will, bräuchte ich eine globale Überdeckung von vielen Satelliten, dass also immer über die allmöglichen Ozeangebiete ständig Satelliten fliegen. Ich brauche also eine Vielzahl von Satelliten. Das ist mit den großen Systemen, die als monolithische Blöcke gebaut werden, zu teuer. Das kann keiner bezahlen. Hier wären Kleinsatelliten genau die richtige Plattform, weil sie eben aufgrund der Kleinheit nicht nur geringere Startkosten haben, sondern eben auch in der Seenproduktion hergestellt werden können und auch dadurch kostengünstiger werden. Das wäre also so ein Beispiel. Das ist jetzt nur mal eins rausgegriffen.
Vor allem die Anwendung wird überhaupt erst durch viele ins Lenkbar.
Ja, und da gibt es eben eine ganze Reihe auch jetzt Internet weltweit zu verbreiten. Auch in Gebieten, die sehr dünn besiedelt sind. Da werden keine Handy-Massen aufgestellt und da wird erst recht kein Internetanschluss gelegt. Da braucht man dann Satellitentechnologien. Und das wäre auch so ein Feld, wenn es so ein Netzwerk von Satelliten gibt, die die Erde mit Kommunikationsverbindungen absichert. Dann die Frage, wie können sich Piloten per Funk verständigen, wenn sie über große Ozeangebiete fliegen? Kann man da ständig den Funkkontakt halten und alle Daten austauschen? Auch da bieten Satelliten eben eine sehr gute Plattform an, sind also eine ganze Reihe von Dingen oder auch die globalen Veränderungen, die jetzt stattfinden. Nicht nur Klima, auch auf der Oberfläche. Städte wachsen unkontrolliert. Jetzt denken wir mal nicht an eine Kleinstadt in Deutschland, sondern an Riesenstädte, Mega-Cities in der Welt, wo die Stadtbehörden keine Ahnung haben, wie sie wirklich sich ausbreiten, wie Landwirtschaftsflächen oder anderes Beispiel, wie Waldflächen gerodet werden und Landwirtschaftsflächen falsch oder umgenutzt werden. Das sind alles Themen, wo man einen globalen Blickwinkel braucht, den eigentlich nur Satelliten bieten können, weil Flugzeuge noch zu tief fliegen und nicht flächendeckend arbeiten können. Dafür brauchen wir aber Kleinsatelliten, damit wir es auch bezahlen können. Das ist so eine Nische. Wenn man aber sowas machen will, dann müssen die Kleinsatelliten leistungsfähig sein. Die können sich also nicht ungefähr ausrichten, ich habe es ungefähr im Weg, das Ziel. Sondern dann muss auch die ganze Technologie stimmen. Und auch die Herstellung der Kleinsatelliten muss anders werden. Das sind ja heutzutage immer noch, mehr oder weniger ist es ein Manufakturprozess. Ja, man macht Einzelfertigung mit allen möglichen Prozessen, Zwischenschritten der Testung und Verifikation und Funktionsprüfung und der nächste Schritt und Wiederverifikation. Alles richtig und wichtig muss sein. Aber wie kann ich sowas in einer Produktionskette verankern? Dass wir so neue Forschungsthemen, die jetzt anstehen, wo man auch hin muss, wenn man solche Satelliten, solche Kleinsatelliten in großen Stückzahlen bauen will. Dieser Trend ist ja jetzt da.
Und der ist ja auch nicht ganz neu, wenn ich mich jetzt mal erinnere. Iridium ist ja im Prinzip auch schon so ein Beispiel eines weltumspannenden Kommunikationssystems, ursprünglich für Satelliten, Telefonie gedacht. Und auch so auch später dann gedutzt. War dann anfangs nicht erfolgreich, wurde dann verkauft und dann trotzdem betrieben. Hat nur sozusagen der Investor das Geld verloren. Aber das sind ja im Prinzip auch schon 66 Satelliten, die permanent in aufeinander abgestimmten Flugbahnen durch die Gegend fliegen. Aber ich denke, Sie sprechen jetzt von noch sehr viel höheren Satellitenzahlen an der Stelle. Ich weiß nicht, wie groß sind überhaupt diese Iridium-Satelliten? Qualifizieren die schon als kleinen Satelliten? Also gerade noch unter 800 sozusagen.
Das sind glaube ich 77 Satelliten. Die wurden eigentlich von der Handy-Technologie überrollt.
77 sollten es mal sein, deswegen der Name, aber am Ende sind sie dann doch mit 66 ausgekommen.
Ja, aber wurden überrollt, konnte man nicht so vorhersehen, dass diese Handy-Technologie sich so rasant entwickelt und überall Sendemasten aufgestellt werden. Und das dann auch noch im Kostenrahmen deutlich unter diesen Satellitelefonen blieb. Ja, heute wird man mit solchen kleinsoliden Hunderte brauchen, die möglichst tief dann im niedrigen Erdorbit fliegen. Und da muss man alle Fragen angehen, auch der Entsorgung und Ersetzung des Netzwerks, wenn das wirklich flächendeckend dort gestaltet werden soll. Und auch die Frage, wie bringe ich sie in Orbit? Wie entfalt ich so ein Netzwerk? Und an solchen Teilthemen arbeiten wir auch. Wir haben ein Forschungsthema, wo wir untersuchen, wie werden Funkverbindungen im Orbit zwischen Satelliten funktionieren. Welche Protokolle muss man dort wählen, damit man mit hohen Datenraten im Orbit in der Satellite Link macht, also zwischen Satelliten Daten austauschen kann.
Gibt es denn das überhaupt schon? Also gibt es Systeme, wo die Satelliten untereinander sprechen?
Also in der Art und Weise, wie wir es jetzt machen, nicht, dass wir also ein Netzwerk entfalten wollen und dort mit einer hohen Bitrate Daten austauschen. Da wollen wir weltweit die ersten sein, 2017. Und was steckt da für eine Idee dahinter? Künftig wird man auch im Orbit Daten prozessieren bis zum Endprodukt und dann das Endprodukt den Nutzern zur Verfügung stellen. Heutzutage ist es ja noch üblich so, dass Verhandlungs-Satelliten Daten aufnehmen, speichern und dann zur Bodenstation senden und dort werden die dann prozessiert mit Zeitverzögerungen und zu den Anwendern geschickt, wo auch noch mal Zeitverzögerungen auftreten, sodass aktuelle Datenprodukte doch ein bis mehrere Tage alt sind. Und das ist dann schon schnell und in Zukunft wird man schon an Bord für bestimmte Aufgaben, nicht für alle Aufgaben, an Bord datensprozessieren bis zum Endprodukt und das dann geokodiert runtersenden, dieses finale Datenprodukt. Dann braucht man auch nur noch einen Datenkanal mit einer relativ limitierten Kanalkapazität. Und unten wird der Nutzer sitzen, der wird sich gar nicht mehr um Prozessierung kümmern müssen. Der hat dort unten ein Geographical Information System, ein GIS-System, eine Karte mit den interessanten Daten für ihn in ein Waldstück oder was auch immer. Und dann kommen die Daten mit einer relativ einfachen Antennentechnologie rauf in seinen Systemreihen, werden sofort zur Anzeige gebracht und er kann sich den Zustand seines Waldes anschauen. Oder wo sind Feuer ausgebrochen, eine Feuerkarte. Sowas wird man dann in Zukunft direkt als Datenprodukt kriegen. Und dafür brauchen wir aber auch geeignete Technologien an Bord. Satelliten werden unterschiedliche Daten auch zusammenführen müssen. Dass man also sagt, wir haben Spektrometadaten aus dem sichtbaren Weldingbereich mit Spektrometadaten aus dem Infraroten-Weldingbereich, die von einem anderen Kleinsatelliten erzeugt werden, die wir zusammenführen in einem dritten Satelliten und der sendet dann das Datenprodukt runter. Das wird also künftig gemacht werden.
Also wenn ich es richtig verstehe, geht es gar nicht mal nur darum, Inter-Satelliten-Kommunikation zu machen, um so Infrastrukturen wie zum Beispiel eine Internetversorgung effizient aufzubauen, weil man will ja nicht immer hoch wieder runter und wenn es irgendwo anders hin muss wieder hoch wieder runter, weil das wäre zu langsam zu ineffizient, sondern da würde es ja sozusagen Sinn machen, nachdem man überhaupt erstmal die Verbindung zu einem Satellit gefunden hat, von dort sozusagen das Satelliten-Netzwerk zur Weiterleitung, so wie das ja im Internet auch an sich funktioniert. Warum sollte das nicht auch außerhalb der 100-Kilometer-Zone funktionieren, aber auch, dass sozusagen eine Koordinierung stattfindet über die zu leistende Gesamtarbeit, dass die Systeme untereinander absprechen, unter Umständen auch gegenseitig ihre Kapazitäten bereitstellen und kollaborativ nutzen, um einfach die Downlinks zu entlasten. Weil ich denke mir heutzutage mit der stark verbesserten Sensorik hat man es vor allem damit zu tun, dass man eigentlich viel zu viele Daten aufnimmt, als dass man sie noch roh weiterleiten konnte, wie das ja bisher eigentlich immer war. Man sammelt erstmal und dann schickt man das irgendwie so über mehrere Tage. Wir haben jetzt gerade die New Horizons Mission gesehen, die jetzt Flux mal am Pluto vorbeigeflogen ist und ich weiß nicht, wie viele Wochen und Monate noch damit beschäftigt ist, diese Daten zurückzuschicken. Gut, das ist natürlich jetzt auch wirklich sehr weit weg, aber im Prinzip sind das dieselben Zwänge. Wäre man in der Lage, diese Aufbereitung schon vor Ort teilweise vorzunehmen, wäre das natürlich viel schneller.
Okay, also ich denke, das kann man jetzt nicht ganz vergleichen.
Ja, ich weiß, das war jetzt etwas weit hergeholt.
Ja, so eine Exploration bis Mission, da will man alle Daten haben, die man kriegen kann.
Aber wir haben ja auch schnell tolle Fotos.
Ja, ne, aber nehmen wir das Beispiel Feuerwehranerkundung, da kenne ich mich ein bisschen aus. Da wäre es schon schön, wenn man an Bord die wirklichen Feuerdaten extrahiert, geokodiert und dann nur noch diese Feuerparameter, Ausdehnung und Geokodierung, runter sendet. Da bräuchte ich einen Datenkanal, der kann eigentlich Kilobit pro Sekunde betragen. Das heißt ganz einfach Antennentechnik. Und am Boden nimmt dann eine Software diese Daten und gibt die auf den Geographical Information System auf dem Display und der Feuermanager weiß sofort Bescheid, wo sind welche Feuer, von welcher Größenordnung und an welchen Temperaturen. Und braucht nicht am Boden die ganze Prozess-Sicherungs-Kette, die sonst der Fall ist.
Kein Rechenzentrum mit extra Experten.
Ja, das wird also die Zukunft sein, dass man dort so etwas macht. Und dafür müssen jetzt die Grundlagen gelegt werden. Und daran arbeiten wir.
Das heißt, die Dienstleistungen würden auch sehr viel unmittelbarer eigentlich schon im Orbit erledigt werden. Und man könnte direkt quasi Nutznieser sein.
Das wird kommen, dass der Endnutzer einen direkten Empfang der Satellitendaten auch bekommt, unmittelbar und nicht zeitverzögert über mehrere Tage durch eine Bodenstation. Das wird es auch geben. Aber das andere wird das Neue sein, was sich weiter verbreitet, dass man mit einfachen Empfangsanlagen direkt Satellitendaten auswertet. Und es wird meiner Meinung nach noch eine andere Tendenz stattfinden, wenn sich so viele Satelliten im Orbit Aufgaben lösen. Dann wird es auch im ganzen Betrieb der Satelliten eine Umstellung geben. Die Satelliten werden autonomer arbeiten und auch autonomer zusammenarbeiten. Es wird in Zukunft auch Schwärme geben von Satelliten. Das heißt, man spricht nicht mehr mit den einzelnen Satelliten und kommandiert jeden Einzelnen, sondern man gibt einem Satellitenschwarm eine Aufgabe. Der Schwarm organisiert die Lösung der Aufgabe mit seinen verschiedenen Knoten, mit seinen verschiedenen Elementen. Er organisiert das selbst, sodass der Nutzer am Boden das fertige Produkt, das fertige Ergebnis erhält und der Betreiber auch selber nicht unbedingt mit jedem einzelnen Satelliten sprechen muss. Das ist also auch noch eine Zukunftsaufgabe.
Solltest du einfach den Kommunikationskanal entlasten oder gibt es da noch andere Vorteile, diese Entscheidung sozusagen so zu delegieren?
Na ja, ich könnte sie jetzt auch als Nachteil darstellen. Der Vorteil ist, sie braucht weniger Personal am Boden, um diesen Satellitenschwarm zu betreiben. Ich habe dann, nehmen wir mal an, es sind 12 Satelliten. Heute geht man ja schon in den Multimissionsbetrieb. Ein Betriebsingenieur steuert mehrere Satelliten, die zeitlich versetzt nacheinander kommen. Aber er guckt sich jeden Einzelnen nochmal an. Das wird in Zukunft so sein, wenn wir jetzt Netzwerke von Satelliten haben, dass man eine Aufgabe gibt in 12 Satelliten. Das ist eine Teilaufgabe, die ein Betriebsingenieur löst. Dann geht er zu den nächsten Dutzend und verteilt eine andere. Er weiß schon gar nicht mehr so genau, welcher Satellit jetzt was macht. Erst wenn er nachguckt und das alles nachvollziehen will. Aber das muss er dann nicht wissen. Das ist ein verteiltes System im Orbit. Das arbeitet dann auch wie ein verteiltes System. Das ist noch nicht Realität. Das ist ein Forschungsthema, dem wir uns auch stellen. Verteiltes System im Orbit. Aber das wird kommen.
Vielleicht noch mal zurück auf die Ausbildung bei ihrem Institut. Das ist ein normaler Ausbildungsgang. Wie heißt er offiziell? Raumfahrtechnik?
Man wird Master für Luft- und Raumfahrtechnik. Und der Student kann eigentlich an der TU Berlin, der seinen Stundenplan auch weitestgehend selber bestimmen. Er kann also sagen, ich möchte eigentlich mehr Luftfahrtingenieur werden und das dann auch mit seiner Fächerwahl entsprechend dokumentieren. Oder er kann auch sagen, ich möchte eigentlich mehr Raumfahrtingenieur werden und möchte alle Fächer, die im Raumfahrtbereich dazu angeboten werden, besuchen. Und er hat einen klaren Schwerpunkt Raumfahrtechnik und kann dann sich in der Raumfahrtindustrie später umgucken oder in Forschungseinrichtungen, die mit Raumfahrt zu tun haben und dort seine Arbeit später finden.
Aber sie haben jetzt auch noch so einen zweiten Studiengang eingeführt, der sich anders organisiert.
Ja, das ist neu bei uns. Wir haben parallel zu diesem deutschsprachigen und deutschen Master für Luft- und Raumtechnik-Studiengang haben wir einen internationalen Masterstudiengang, Master for Space Engineering gesetzt, der Studenten aus aller Welt anzieht. Dort haben wir ungefähr 20 Studenten, die zum Master für Space Engineering ausgebildet werden, aber die schon Berufserfahrung mitbringen. Das ist ein weiterbildender Studiengang. Sie müssen also schon vorher einen Bachelor-Abschluss in einem entsprechenden Beruf haben und auch mindestens ein Jahr Berufspraxis nachweisen können. Und dann haben sie die Voraussetzungen erfüllt. Es ist ein gebührenpflichtiger Studiengang, im Unterschied zu den Studiengangs, sonst in Deutschland müssen wir sagen, es ist ein gebührenpflichtiger Weiterbildungsstudiengang, weil wir alle Lehrkapazitäten, die wir dazu brauchen, auch zusätzlich ran organisieren. Das heißt, wir kaufen Dozenten, Lehrleistungen von verschiedenen Universitäteneinrichtungen, Industrie, Forschungseinrichtungen. Das ist also ein Zusatzauffang, den wir tragen. Das ist aber eine sehr interessante Sache, weil diese Internationalität auch eine typische Charakteristik im Raumfahrtbereich ist. Der Raumfahrt funktioniert eigentlich über internationale Zusammenarbeit. Deutschland ist stark im Raumfahrtbereich, aber kann auch keine eigenen Dinge in den Weltraum selber bringen, sondern braucht dazu eine Startmöglichkeit. Entweder eine europäische, oder eine amerikanische, oder eine russische, oder eine indische, oder eine chinesische, aber sie braucht eine andere Nummer als Beispiel. Insofern ist Raumfahrt von sich aus international und das finde ich eigentlich auch so interessant im Raumfahrtbereich, diese vielen internationalen Kontakte, die man zwangsläufig hat und auch pflegen möchte, die Bereiche aneignen und das finde ich eben toll, dass wir jetzt auch so einen Studiengang haben, wo wirklich, wenn man sich das auf der Karte anschaut, über die Weltkarte verteilt, die Studenten herkommen. Also von Südkorea, Europa bis nach Argentinien, da kommen unsere Studenten her.
Bringt das auch neue Einflüsse in den Lehr- und Forschungsbetrieb, so wie er sich bisher aus sich selbst heraus entwickelt hat? Ist das sozusagen auch so eine Anleihe für konzeptionelle Veränderungen in der Zukunft, was die Lehre an sich betrifft in diesem Bereich?
Ja, ist es auf jeden Fall. Das eine ist diese kulturelle Vielfalt, die man hat, und das andere ist auch der unterschiedliche Hintergrund der Leute. Die haben ja schon Berufserfahrung. Das ist ja nicht so wie unsere Studenten sonst, die sehr gut sind, aber die eben noch nicht diese Erfahrungen haben. Also dort kommen auch andere Fragen. Dafür haben die auf anderen Gebieten eben auch nicht diese Vorbildung, die unsere Studenten haben, weil sie eben den Bachelor schon bei uns durchlaufen haben, können wir da auch ganz anders aufbauen. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, die einen sind besser und die anderen sind weniger gut, sondern es sind einfach Unterschiede. Und dieses Semester haben wir zum ersten Mal auch beide Gruppen in einer Lehrveranstaltung bei mir zusammengeführt. Und das finde ich eigentlich besonders schön, dass jetzt auch die sich dort miteinander erst mal warm werden muss und auch miteinander kommuniziert und fachlich austauscht. Ich glaube, es ist eine Bereicherung für alle Seiten, dass die deutsche Seite jetzt auch mit der internationalen verknüpft ist und die internationale noch noch enger mit der deutschen Seite.
Verstärkt sich auch noch das Aufgabenfeld. Mit den kleinen Satelliten haben wir jetzt schon ausführlich besprochen, ist ja sehr viel abgedeckt bereits, was die klassische Raumfahrt als solche betrifft. Gibt es denn auch noch andere Aufgabenfelder, die da jetzt noch mit dazukommen in der Zukunft?
Ja, nicht nur in der Zukunft, sondern auch jetzt schon. Es hat sich über die Jahre gezeigt, dass wir mit unserer Miniaturisierung von Raumfahrt-Techniken, mit dieser Forschungsrichtung und den praktischen Ergebnissen, die wir erzielen, dass man das ja nicht nur für Satelliten einsetzen kann, sondern auch für Rover-Technologien. Wie können wir ein Rover gestalten, aufbauen auf den Erkenntnissen, die wir über Satellitentechnik haben? Und das ist eine ganz interessante Geschichte, die wir jetzt auch mit Unterstützung des DLR durchführen konnten. Wir haben uns zweimal am Wettbewerb beteiligt, am Spaceport Cup, der zum Inhalt hatte, einen autonomen arbeitenden Rover für bestimmte Aufgaben am Mars oder auf dem Mond zu entwickeln, durch Studenten in der studentischen Ausbildung. Und das gehen die Studenten mit sehr viel Engagement an. Wir bekommen Mittel, dass man Bauteile kaufen kann und Dinge verbauen kann. Wir lassen viele Teile in unserer Institutswerkstatt fertigen. Wir haben dort jetzt einen 90 Kilogramm schweren Rover. Fahrfertig, der kann sich autonom im Gelände orientieren. Den können wir also aussetzen. Der beherrscht die Technologie des Simultaneous Localization and Mapping. Das ist also gleichzeitig eine Karte aufnehmen der Umgebung und sich selber darin auch noch wiederfinden. Und dann soll er in dieser Karte oder in dieser Umgebung auch noch bestimmte besondere Bauteile finden, die versteckt wurden, das war Teil des Wettbewerbs. Und autonom nehmen, greifen können, mit einem Greifer ablegen und zu einem Ziel bringen. Und das kann dieser Roboter und viel Know-how von unseren Satelliten konnten wir übernehmen, aber natürlich auch viel Neues gelernt. Der hat eine ganz andere Autonomiestufe, einen ganz anderen Grad der Automatismen als ein Satellit, der ja vom Boden regelmäßig überwacht wird. Der muss hier auch, der muss zwar auf Kommandos auch reagieren können, aber muss auch völlig autonom fahren können. Das ist eine sehr interessante Sache, wo auch wieder die Praxis sehr eng verbunden wird mit Theoriausbildung und Forschung. Und dann haben wir noch eine zweite Linie oder eine dritte, muss man sagen, Satelliten, Rover-Technologien. Und die Studenten, die sich für Antriebstechnologien interessieren, die können auch selber eine Rakete entwerfen, bauen und starten. Vor einer Woche kam eine Gruppe von zehn Studenten und ein Mitarbeiter wieder aus Kirona zurück, aus Schweden. Und sie haben dort zwei selbst entworfene, gebaute Raketen gestartet. Die sind 5.800 Meter hoch geflogen und dürfen gar nicht in Deutschland gestartet werden. Das sind auch einmalige Geschichten, die sind auch vom Deutschen Zentrum für Luft- und Raumfahrt gefördert. Das Deutsche Zentrum für Luft- und Raumfahrt möchte damit eine praxisnahe Ausbildung von Raketenexperten sichern, sodass auch unsere Raumfahrtindustrie, die auch für Raketenbauteile baut, eine ordentliche Nachwuchs hat. Wir sind nicht die einzige Universität, die das macht, aber wir waren bei den ersten drei, die das starten durften.
Zum Schluss noch mal ein kleiner Schwenk auf die nächsten kleinen Satelliten-Experimente und Projekte, die jetzt bei Ihnen anstehen. Also der BISAT ist schon unterwegs. Was kommt als nächstes?
Wir haben BISAT 1 bis 3 in den Orbit gebracht. BISAT 4 ist jetzt in der Fertigstellung und soll nächstes Jahr mit dem DLR-Satelliten BIROS gemeinsam starten, aus dem BIROS selber heraus starten und macht dann dort ein Formationsflug-Experiment. Das heißt, beide Satelliten bleiben für eine bestimmte Zeit sehr eng beieinander. Dafür sorgt der BIROS-Satellit, der hat ein eigenes Antriebssystem. Diese Satelliten driften normalerweise auseinander. Und man braucht dann immer ein paar Impulse, um wieder bei dem anderen zu bleiben. Das wird der BIROS-Satellit machen. Und dann werden wir demonstrieren mit dem BISAT 4, dass GPS-Daten auch von solchen ganz kleinen CubeSats empfangen und ausgewertet werden können. Und dass der CubeSat selber seine Position im Orbit mit einem präzisen Anbord-Orbit-Modell bestimmen kann. Also der nächste Start im nächsten Jahr wird dieser BIROS-Satellit sein. Vom DLR. Die starten mit der indischen Rakete. Mit der PSLV starten sie. Und unser Satellit wird von dem BIROS dann ausgestartet. Der BISAT 4.
So ähnlich wie jetzt FILE am Bebeten rausgeschubst wurde sozusagen?
Vom Prinzip ja. Sonst kann man die aber nicht vergleichen.
Das wollte ich auch nicht tun. Aber ich fand gerade diesen kleinen dezenten Schubzer, der dort durchgeführt wurde, besonders elegant.
Das ist schon eine Wahnsinnsleistung, was da vollbracht wurde in der ESA-Mission. Das muss man schon sagen. Tolle Sache.
Ja, aber auch eine tolle Sache, was an Ihrem Institut stattfindet. Ich bedanke mich für den Einblick hier in die Kleinsatellitenwelt, die gar nicht so klein ist. Und vor allem auch noch eine ganze Menge Potenzial hat. Gerade diese Miniaturisierung und das Potenzial auch die Satelliten quasi am Fließband herzustellen, was natürlich auch die Kosten dann noch enorm senken wird, denke ich mal, wird noch so einige interessante Anwendungen bringen. Und vielleicht dann auch diese Satellitennetzwerke sehr viel zugänglicher machen für eine größere Öffentlichkeit, die sich dort technisch einbringen will, die man sozusagen selber dort die Möglichkeit hat, an diesem Netz auch als mehr oder weniger unabhängiger mit zu forschen. Sehen Sie da auch einen Weg dahin?
Ja, ich denke auch, dass das ist bisher noch gar nicht so möglich, dass der einzelne, direkten Zugang hat zu diesen Technologien. Ich denke, da wird auch eine Nutzung hingehen, dass man unmittelbarer mit Satellitentechnologien konfrontiert wird. Man hat es heutzutage auch, man weiß es gar nicht mehr. Wenn ich jetzt Fernsehen gucke, da kommt es irgendwie aus dem Kabel raus. Aber irgendwo ist es ja auch über den Satelliten gelaufen. Zum großen Teil jedenfalls. Alle Sehkabel reichen nicht aus, um die Datenverbindung sicherzustellen. Man braucht die Satelliten. Man weiß gar nicht, ob es nur über Sehkabel oder über Satelliten kam, wenn man Nachrichten aus aller Welt fast live zu sehen bekommt. Und ich denke, dieser unmittelbare Zugriff auf Satellitentechnologien, sei es irgendwelche Dinge beobachten, die weiter weg sind, bestimmte Wettererscheinungen in der Hochatmosphäre, die wir jetzt noch gar nicht sehen können, erforschen, das wird man mit solchen kleinen Satelliten neu erschließen können und auch viel mehr den Menschen zugänglich machen können.
Wenn ich mir anschaue, wie so Sensornetzwerke jetzt hier am Boden auch zunehmend in den Fokus geraten und man einfach durch die Vernetzung einfach die Möglichkeit hat, auf einmal sehr viele Kleinstdaten an sehr vielen Mengen zu machen. Ich denke nur so an Radioaktivitätsmessungen in Japan, die ja auch von unabhängigen Projekten schon durchgeführt wurden. Wenn man das dann auch noch in den Orbit verlagern kann, dann wird es noch richtig spannend.
Ja, ich denke auch, dass vielleicht die Webcam im Weltraum steht vor der Tür. Danke Ihnen für das Gespräch.
Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Raumzeit. Wir machen bald weiter.